ja es ist wieder soweit ist werden
plätzchen gebacken dass die hütte
knattert es werden plätzchen gebacken
dass der ofen nicht mehr zu atem kommen
und die frage mich schon lange warum
schmecken eigentlich die selbstgemachten
plätzchen tausendmal besser als die vom
discounter gekauften also außer meine
die plätze am tisch mit sehr gut die
fristen der nachbar so auch nicht wenn
ich jedes plätzchen einzeln in dem 500
apa einblicke fragen über fragen die
antwort kennt nur der wind und der sorgt
nix also frage ich einen experten und
natürlich nicht irgendeinen experten
sondern den experten der experten den
experten für alles und jedes karl
lauterbach lauterbach ich grüße sie
grüße sie herr lanz
grünwald dynamisch grünwald erwachen sie
da keine vorwürfe
ja schön herr lauterbach lieferketten
engpässe überall müssen wir uns jetzt
sorgen machen dass es dieses jahr keine
zuckersüßen platz zu weihnachten gibt
frau will ich habe im vorfeld der
sendung habe ich noch nicht ein experte
vom drk institut gesprochen da haben wir
bestätigt dass wir uns da keine sorgen
machen müssen denn entscheidend beim
plätzchenbacken sie nicht die inzidenz
sondern die ihnen regieren zu nase die
zutaten aber nord axel studien kommen da
keine bedrohlichen engpässe auf uns zu
gott sei dank ja und was die zutaten an
ging sie zur empfehlung für mich ja das
verwenden sie unbedingt absolut frische
zutaten dafür kein weg vorbei sollten
also zum beispiel die a ja schon bald
über den verfallsdatum hinaus seien da
kann es sehr schnell zu einer selbst
verordneten quarantäne kommen also um
das grabmal für den laien zu
veranschaulichen habe ich auch mal eine
grafik mitgebracht
ja das klingt durchaus nachvollziehbar
herr lauterbach was dann eigentlich ihre
lieblingsplätze ich vermute einfach nur
im stern ich und spritz bogen
aus gesundheitlichen gründen verzichtet
komplett auf süße backwaren ein
plätzchen hat man die gesundheitlichen
gefahren in keinster weise unterschätzen
dass sich die experten einig denn die
können dann verbraucher zu
exponentiellen wachstum führen vor allem
beim bauch
des coni bestätigen gay war richtiger
platz und friedhof ich kann an dieser
stelle nur eindringlich warnen in ihrem
fall plädiere ich dafür dass ja also
beschränkung hat ein hat und was den
kontakt zu plätzchen angeht und zum
anderen strikte einhaltung der
sogenannten
dreijähriger maximal drei plätzen am tag
überhaupt
vielen dank herr lauterbach und grüße
sie jan lanz von mir gerne frau
aus terminlichen gründen haben wir das
interview vor der sendung aufgezeichnet
war jetzt hier überhaupt zeit dazu
reiche auch nicht ja